uh if you look beyond you see if
scandals you see some pretty positive
things first look abroad China sending
an envoy to North Korea why Donald Trump
Isis is nearly destroyed as Syria
Institute's terrorists rehab hope
there's yoga so what's the difference
there Trump back here consumer
confidence is high reflecting a
country's mood under a new president if
you think the guy wants to do business
you're more inclined to do it - that's
Trump there's other stuff illegal
immigration is down Trump our energy
policy seems adult for once that's Trump
yet what do we see the same names and
faces unloading bitter comedy that they
presume is edgy when it's actually the
opposite Joe Scarborough a poor man's
Sonny Bono is releasing a record called
a very drunk Christmas Trump was the
name that liberals tried to stick on
Trump it failed cuz it wasn't memorable
much like Joe and Alec Baldwin said in a
speech that you can't be mean enough to
Trump which raises the question how can
you be meaner than chopping off his head
so what you're seeing is more cognitive
bias clouding how they see everything if
Trump does good it's pure dumb luck but
if he does bad it's because he's evil
but try explaining that illusion to Joe
or Alec the world's moved on without
them they're like comedians doing jokes
about y2k or Britney Spears the
materials moldy er than a dorm room
shower curtain but to them it still
smells new but also Trump's funnier and
I saw this man on television just now
you and I see him standing and didn't
you get here like at 4:00 in the morning
say a couple of words
should I let them have a little bit more
what do you think Peter this Peter
should I have let him have a little
business sit down sit down
so how does the press treat you I'll bet
you get treated better by the quest than
anybody in the world right thousand jobs
thank you they don't have order
japanese manufacturers is a national
treasure
no wonder Joe and alak can't quit him
that's pure entertainment
Trump's better at it than they are isn't
that the problem Juan he's having more
fun his critics and so it's hard for
critics to keep making jokes oh poor joe
scarborough is now doing novelty songs
which is kind of the last bastion for a
has-been to start doing novelty songs
he'll be at speakers corner with a
little banjo like one weirdly was that a
[ __ ] that the Japanese guy roses eyes
yeah yeah yeah cheek was so I guess
strong no I didn't know anyway anyway he
is a funny guy on that level yeah it's
too bad he's not just an entertainer cuz
if he was like Joe Scarborough I'd say
great but no he's not I mean he's the
President of the United States that's
why greatest one ever at G's that's what
you said yes right the greatest
president I mean if you look at the
numbers Greg people who aren't comedians
don't think I mean his poll numbers are
sinking fast but you know wait this we
go to this back Kimberly you don't have
to be popular and right you don't still
vote for you even if they don't like you
if they trust you or think you're gonna
be good absolutely and this just goes to
show you the inherent grotesque
disgusting contagious bias that no
matter what he does they're not going to
give him the credit but the good thing
about the president is he's not bothered
by it he's going to keep forging ahead
and make sure that he accomplishes the
goals and the promises that he made to
the hard-working men and women across
this country they were forgotten that's
who he feels he's beholden to and that's
why he's honoring the pledges and
promises about jobs and stimulating the
economy and building the ball Jesse you
know the South Park decided months ago
they weren't gonna come bash Trump any
more because they felt it was too happy
that it was like they just had enough
but these guys keep going
yeah it's all played out but they won't
stop ya Biden was asked what Trump's
greatest accomplishment has been so far
and he goes well he married well yeah
and salons point his poll numbers may be
down but he still beats Hillary Clinton
excuse me
crooked Hillary Clinton are you mean he
beat her in the pack if the election
were held today I still lose and those
are your polls this woman Frederica
Wilson though Congress somebody was
going after she beats them all these
people beating each other
Gillian first of all yes Jessie's mother
is right sometimes you make good points
okay so kudos for that monologue kudos
thank you and I'm gonna steal that
comedy montage and use it on my weekend
together
you know Joe Scarborough should get
together with the Capitol Steps remember
that they have the best time and he
plays over a prohibition I don't care
Kimberly I don't care what about what we
talked yesterday about of any Talent
yes what can you I have many talents
Kimberly and should I don't about what
about things not having to be black or
white I mean not to be boring but it's
real I guess yes don't write not
everything is like my dress
no there's residency's are never clear
cut this trip was no ye-yeah trip was
not clear cut it had successes it had
shortcomings
just like everything you know a foreign
policy is that early cut and dry Jillian
the last thing table the last thing
cable TV needs is ambiguity it's either
black or it's white now you need to get
your things take your things that go
that's fine now they want me to teach
leave they want me to tease two minutes
ago all right